I want to welcome everybody to our
celebration of the American Yiddish
theater and its music and I want to say
that this is a program that also
celebrates the 25th anniversary of the
Joseph and Roslyn Newman grant to the
Yale University Library of an endowment
of Yiddish Yiddish literature and it's
known as the Joseph and Rosalind Newman
Yiddish literature collection it was a
very generous gift and it has enabled us
over the years this is the 25th
anniversary of collecting all kinds of
wonderful items and Yiddish starting
with books and manuscripts and also
sheet music and we have by now a very
large and wonderful collection of yet a
sheet music which takes us back to the
beginning of Yiddish speaking
immigration of Jews Jews who spoke
Yiddish as their native language to the
United States we also have actually a
lot of music from Europe and from Israel
than Palestine that goes back to the
beginning of the 20th century as well
and even earlier but today we're going
to celebrate particularly American
Yiddish theater music which was at the
time of that it existed it at a day at
the beginning of the 20th century and
probably into the 30s so popular and of
the immigrant community went to these
theaters
to them on Second Avenue to to sort of
take in the Yiddish world that they had
come from and to meet each other and
also to begin to Americanize because it
was really also their entry into
American life and culture and the it'sh
stars of the day Thomas F ski and I'm
trying to think of some others i'm sure
many of you could well mark Mark's logan
who was about to speak will tell you
about it were like gods you know they
were they were it and they sang and they
dance and they acted and they were
wonderful and so we're really thrilled
to be able to have this event here today
and it came about through a
collaboration of the program of the
program in Judaic Studies at the library
and the music library who made it all
possible Ruth Ann Mac Mac tire who is
the melon music librarian at at the
music library and Suzanne Lovejoy who
worked tirelessly to make this happen
who is the assistant librarian for
public services at the music library and
a musician herself and then of course
all the wonderful singers who are going
to participate later but we also thought
we should have a little background in
history of of the theater and and we
invited two great scholars to come and
speak as well and I am now going to
introduce to you Ruth anak tire who is
our music librarian who will introduce
our speakers
now that had a great idea and Suzanne
and I have been thrilled to have the
opportunity to work with her on this
project so I know you're going to have
an enjoyable afternoon ahead of you it's
my pleasure to introduce our two
speakers this afternoon mark slobin the
Winslow Kaplan professor of music at
Wesleyan University will speak on
Yiddish sheet music in the tenement era
and Michael Ochs who is the retired
French music Richard French music
librarian at Harvard University and a
senior lecturer on music when he was
there who will speak about tailoring and
operetta to its audience room since Keys
d cold in the kala of 1923 I could go on
but I know we want to get started with
the lectures so I'm going to turn the
mic over to mark to get started and
welcome mark thank you well this is this
is fun I always loved any opportunity to
get back to this sheet music that I was
fell in love with about well a long time
ago 40 years in before so I'm going to
start with a little social history to
situate what it is we're talking about
in listening to today simply like how
did this happen that this was possible
what were the conditions in which this
flourished and then where I'm going to
kind of unpack what we are calling seat
music I actually didn't bring one I was
going to a seat music folio which
consists of different components um so
we'll go into cases to analyze the music
the packaging itself okay of the of the
songs so when we talk about yet as
popular culture Yiddish theater and this
very generally what does this mean we're
talking about people who spoke Yiddish
as a native language as a vernacular
language in Eastern Europe which they
had been doing for about a thousand
years and they did have popular culture
it's not like it was totally an artifact
of modernity but the kind of popular
culture we're talking about is a purely
a modern phenomenon that is to say they
read books they circulated books they
are but they didn't have what we would
think of as
popular culture and what do I mean by
that I mean media I mean commodification
a system of circulation a group of
people who are professionals the idea of
technologies that emerge new
technologies which allow for mass
distribution for large audiences
gathered in urban spaces that that sort
of thing that's what we mean by popular
culture this was not possible until the
Jews moved into that context which they
did in Europe on beginning in the 1850s
60s 70s and particularly with the spread
of the railroads which allowed Jews to
get on trains and move around and to
take songs from place to place and for
theater troupes to spring up they could
move from place to place easily things
like that just did not happen before the
official invention of the Yiddish
theater is usually given as 1876 in a
town called Gaussian Romania which has
to do with the russo-turkish Wars and a
can of time to go into all those
histories but these guys are created
what became a professional theater
exactly at the moment when immigration
started to the United States so it's not
like there was an old tradition of
Yiddish theater in the addition
entertainment of utich vaudeville before
the immigration okay so this is a
simultaneous phenomenon the audience is
and the performers just as they're
getting this thing down oh sorry just as
they're getting this together they're
all getting on the same ships and going
to America and eighty percent of them
end up in New York City you have this
gigantic population that never existed
anywhere in Jewish culture of people who
are all striving and living in this you
know condensed it was the densest part
of the United States at that time to
population was this allowed for a market
okay and so it allowed for this kind of
as I say this class of entertainers not
only that and allow for consumer culture
and a scale which you had not seen
before so as the sound recording has
just been invented and it takes a while
to percolate through so that people have
record players at home that's a you know
pianos are something that people needed
to have in their homes they decided they
were sold on this as upward mobility in
European
in that particular in America and so you
get a nexus of entertainment based on
new technologies and a kind of bourgeois
sensibility even though these are very
poor people who are as we know working
in sweatshops and so forth so you have
the phenomenon of a store which sells
pianos it sells on which you can rest
the sheet music that you buy and which
you will buy the recording they will
sell you the recording and they'll sell
you the record player okay and all of
that is available on installments for
the first time in history you could walk
you could get these things on
installments and so um they sold an
ideology so it's a certain kind of
bourgeois ideology which in a sense has
nothing to do with the other sky it's
about upward mobility and in a situation
that they're the people are craving this
so that's the kind of background sheet
music itself is a product of lithography
lithography is a pretty late invention
the idea that you could put out a
million copies say and sell a million
copies of a piece of music doesn't
happen till the late 19th century
anywhere in the world America is held
together by popular culture unlike
Europe and traditionally and so these
products these techniques these
technologies as we know being flooded by
media today are part of American life so
they're tapping into and making use of
that system the other side of popular
culture however is is a different
meaning of the word that is the st.
comes from the people it's something
that is popular that people recognize
and identify with okay and so this is
not a system of popular cultures we
think of with distant celebrities
faraway Muzak capitals this is based on
knowing everything about the people that
produce this and living side by side
with them so that's another version of
what we would call popular theater
traditions which go back thousands of
years and are still in many parts of the
world but in the 19th century you had in
Paris and such places and in New York
where you have stars living in
neighborhoods where people see them they
hear about their they can literally hear
them arguing you know the wife and the
husband then they go on stage and they
act out a husband one wife arguing and
everybody knows what this is about
really or they
they know what it's about that feeling
of being close to the people that are
producing your culture is another side
of popular culture okay so there's kind
of two sides to this whole question what
we mean by this the theater was one
place but they were also vaudeville
shows and dives and bars and low-grade
entertainment which was much more
knockabout much more raunchy ER and and
maybe more you know lively but we have
very little record of that almost no
record of that what we have is the
record of what you would call the
legitimate theater of the interstage
because one of the things that happen
was that they produced all this music
not all of the music you're going to
hear today by the way is from the
Yiddish theater some of it is just pop
songs they were pop songs that we're not
on the interstate stage so that's a kind
of basic background I think I've covered
most of that and then you get these
stars like the Thomas have skis husband
and wife and so forth Jacob Adler and a
whole lot of other people okay so what
I'm going to do is talk about the actual
artifact the edge of the sheet music
folio folio is usually four pages the
covers you've all been exposed to the
covers because they are on the poster
and I'm going to talk first about that
this is what we call iconography okay in
academia what are these pictures how do
they work what's on what is the
information so what I did I got a
collection of this stuff I got a stack
of it because I could still go to Hebrew
publishing company was still on delancey
street and they let me go upstairs and
pull things out of the old off the
shelves which would bring in packets
from the printer unopened since nineteen
eleven after that they closed and all of
this has been sold off in archived
various places but I was able to get my
own thing so what I did is just simply
stare at this stuff when you open it you
see a very simple mind of music it's so
that because any shop girl can play it
who gets a few lessons that's this is
not virtual image with rare exceptions
and you get the song text so you have
some texts which are in Yiddish but
sometimes they're bilingual sometimes
your uterus and English too which makes
it Italy interesting because they tell
different stories
then you have and then you have the back
cover which I mean if I were doing an
hour or two we'd go into all that stuff
the back cover is that usually the
catalog of the publishers which gives
you the other listings and that's
enormously useful they make less
classical music that they sell to or
other songs that you know and so forth
so it's a complex artifact it's very
very dense and interesting so I'm going
to do is a couple examples are going to
go quickly through some iconography
issues then I'm going to play some music
and maybe we'll actually all sing
something when I get to the end of that
try not to go too far to run too long
but this stuff is so attractive ok so
this really fascinated me it's the kind
of thing fascinated me maybe i will take
the mic out so I can kind of look at
this and talk about it at the same time
it wouldn't work easily ok so um what do
we got here these are two seat music
covers on the Left we have a mix pension
on the right rough mono Donna okay these
are what is here let's look at the left
side here what strike says I mean this
is course when I do this in class we
just kind of go around and try to what
are the components but i'll just tell
you what's there what's there is a lot
of our nouveau figuration so its up with
the times it's doing modern european
stuff okay that's that's our new vote
hidden in the art nouveau at the top our
candlesticks that's Jewish okay so what
we get is a wonderful interactive
pattern between mainstream and sub
cultural I kind of graphic components in
these covers you also get so let's look
at this a little quickly we have h a
risotto that's not his real name he
thought was otto sounded better it was
Italian it would be more musical we have
here the hebrew publishing company why
hebrew because that's what the jews were
called in America then was Hebrews
there's a liar the liar is not Jewish
but it is Jewish tits King David but
it's also on in every piano and the
parlor had like the pedals run a liar is
as a joint mainstream subculture
structure now the main thing though is
the language here now let's look at the
picture first so what is the picture the
picture is seems to be a woman blessing
the candles in a Sabbath dinner it is
done archetypal II okay we don't know
who she is she has no name and it's done
as a drawing as a line drawing okay the
text is in two languages the Yiddish
lift mention is buried in the filigree
and the main thing you see that draws
your eye immediately is the romanization
that means that they're selling this is
in a shop windows this is what people
are buying so it's as packaging so they
think it's more important to put the two
foreground the transliteration than the
original so we know we're readying a
point of transition okay even though
this is only like 1911 where
transliteration is important okay all
right let's compare it to the right so
this is a a song about piety and being
doing the right thing and being a good
Jewish woman and it's a very very in
group didactic there's like a lot of
Jewish folklore is didactic okay oh and
the Hasidic communities in Brooklyn by
the way really have a lot of these songs
still and young adult fiction about
girls growing out to be proper Jewish
women so this has not disappeared on the
right we have a lot of texts this is
brilliant for historians okay we've got
from kantar serratos concert repertoire
then there's some Hebrew then that's it
for the Hebrew and we go through the
transliteration the liturgical melody
sung by Kendra's road with overwhelming
success and his American concert tour
composed by Leo mo musical director to a
mosque and synagogue wars arranged for
voice with piano organ accompaniment and
copyright 1912 most of these things were
not copyrighted I did copyright checks
for a sample with these they put down
copyright but they never sent a copy to
library of congress you very rarely ok
so the difference between the one on the
left and right although they're both
connected to religious practice the one
on the right has
a line drawing of a synagogue which
looks kind of like the tomatillo
synagogue the Great Synagogue of horse
on that was destroyed during World War
two but it's got photographs and the
photograph are to the cantor and the
composer the positioning of the Cantor
Omega it doesn't like being asleep I
mean it doesn't like being awake compact
coming the canter is he is the synagogue
that's the content of the synagogue is
the counter and that's true about sahota
he was a massively important was the
first star cantor in terms of making
records okay and he went back and forth
to Europe he's an American concert
tourism or so poor Sirota however
happened to be in warsaw in 1939 and
perished he stood have been on New York
tour that year he would have survived
okay I'm going to run through some of
these for it so you get the idea of what
iconography studies offers us um so and
I'm going to go through a bunch of these
okay so here on the Left we have what we
just saw there's that same synagogue so
do you have canonical images you have a
stereotype bunch of imagery that is the
synagogue and it looks like that that
senega and we have in this case um yo
sola Rosenblatt as the end of winter
bike isn't it wonderful like if you know
he in the portico right there there
isn't again he is the heart of the
synagogue and this is very much like
what we saw except doesn't have all that
our Nouveau stuff it's much more sober
on the right we've got absolutely one of
my totally favorite covers at whoops why
did you do that thank you ok this is a
song from gold thousand who was the
founder of the Yiddish theater and that
song is called other wandering jew in
english in yiddish it says a Yid bist du
gave aight of gay which is you're a Jew
so move on which is part of the song
text it's not the same The Wandering Jew
is a literary European reference
whereas this is the actual but now what
is so wonderful here and it's one of my
favorites maybe I'll bow it up a little
for you is this drawing this drawing is
phenomenal so what do we get on this
drawing on the left on the right side we
have a scene of classical ruins there's
like a Roman temple and palm trees we
have the figure looking out at the
camera so to speak I'm wandering jew who
is an antique guy with a shepherd's
staff on the Left we have America ok we
have a steamer coming into the harbor we
have the Brooklyn Bridge so um he is
poised between those two but he's not an
East European immigrant he is the
prototypical that cannot do he's an
archetypal June so these ideas of
archetypes are really important in the
eye in the iconography and so I'll just
give you a couple more archetypes um and
that also represent another side of this
which is what they call what we call toe
terrico territorial connections the Jews
lived with a lot of other people and the
music was seared and we call that Co
territorial okay this is coty art or
music it is not Jewish music but it's
published by hebrew publishing it's used
by Jews on the Left we have the album
music outro mana and we even have the
right diacritics over the a's they're so
real romanian and this is an archetype
it's these are archetypal romanian
sanborns so they're rendered also not in
photography but through drawing okay
they're archetypal figures why is there
an album of romanian music well that's
you know we could talk about that we
don't of time on the right we have oi
diminish gun oil welcome aeonium but
it's william and vapid videos estoy alla
in the older orthography of russian why
is this wise hebrew publishing doing a
russian folk song that Tchaikovsky used
in one of his symphonies why they doing
these things because the co territorial
came with them
okay and so they're in America but they
are still anchored in another life at
this point to the extent of needing akko
territorial in their music okay on and
this goes on so these are other the
Shepherd this is the doers separate hey
the Jewish separate as you'll notice and
we already saw him before but here's a
woman the Jewish Shepherd is not
rendered ethnographically like the
Romanian Shepherd it's rendered
archetypal way because it's biblical so
there is this thing we are the biblical
people that never changes this is not an
East European image again and this goes
on into the 1920s there in the right on
the end this is a stock cover so they
had stalked covers when this one is
caught either folks leader Jewish folk
songs yet as folk songs and that you get
stalked covers so I'm going to do one
more of these because it will go on and
on sort of forever with this it's so
fascinating i'll do another pairing
let's do the one on the right first the
one on the right is that classic nexus
that I've just been talking about first
of all we have the photograph of the
composer's so composers were celebrities
enough to be used as photographs you
know the real person needed to be there
why we're paramotor involved so
important to people that their
photograph had to be in the image but
this is another stock cover and has
nothing to do with the content because
the content is over a phone which is a
very serious liturgical thing the image
has nothing to do with this okay this is
a stock image what do we have here we
have what this thing says to you as you
go and we'll see it in the window is
this is what you do with me you buy me
you take me home you put me on the piano
you rented or bought and the girl
dressed in this beautiful flowing outfit
will play for the delight of these
people now these are clearly the old
folks whether that's her brother or a
boyfriend i'm not sure but he's there
all you see what I mean about upward
mobility they're all extremely
all dressed is this the way you sit
around a tenement on a Friday night
probably not but this is a this is an
aspirational okay but it's also
commercial it's it's a commodified
package so that gives us some sense of
that do maybe you just want more things
because we have to talk about the
theater a little on the Left we have
stuff that advertises itself as being
from the theater this is from the
successful play viable shimoga and which
is the women's Kingdom when they'll get
to that when we get the songs and wow
I've got to move quicker than I'm moving
so hard to do this here we have that's
bessie thomashefsky coming in the window
and her pants with a gun and here are
the archetype oh uh East Europe types
okay the the Hasidic type characters so
this is Europe and America put next side
by side okay uh and then it's a folio of
songs actually are we doing damage goes
I think yeah that's right this is
damaged goods okay I'll just throw in
one more thing and then I'm going to
move to the music itself because this is
Irving Berlin the same time exactly the
same time Irving Berlin is moving out of
this he is not writing for the mirror
anymore he has left he has walked all
the way up to fourteenth street from the
far east side and is selling songs and
becomes a famous songwriter ok so the
option was to leave this world and to
make it an American culture big time and
the people we're going to hear on the
program didn't do that either they
couldn't or they didn't want to they
stayed in the community and of course
that's wonderful and that's why we have
all this terrific music because those
people stayed and serve their community
instead of doing what but notice that
the violin and this Yiddish very Yiddish
this is called a ragtime violin does
this look like a ragtime player so we
have the continuity of certain images
that we have here ok the of the Jew and
the violin going over into the
stream okay so that's all I can do with
iconography I want to do a little with
actual music and listen to a couple
things and um let's see what we can do
with that no this is it ok we're going
to listen to a couple of things when we
can't do too many you're going to hear
so many we don't need to listen to so
many ok so what I want to do is play
just a little sonic sense of what it was
performed like originally which probably
Michael will do as well but just a
contrast between old generation and
newer generation sounds and of cost and
some of the ideological and orientations
of the people in the in the community so
first thing that plays just a little hit
off of a song from the Yiddish theater
but an 1897 yet is show ok nice still
back in the 19th century recorded 20
years later in 1917 which means that
show and this these songs were still
somewhere in memory or columbia records
would not have put it out this is a i
describe this play in great length in my
book tenement songs which you can still
buy and I put that I put that entire for
act melodrama on at wesleyan in 1976 it
seems impossible and people were not
exactly doing that in schools like
Wesley at that time was one of the first
things and Michael's carrying on this
great tradition of doing modern
adaptations of the old music and so I
did that in English very deliberately
back then okay so here's the song this
is its cantorial it's slightly operatic
it's really creaky and the sound quality
is you know like the sound quiet but I'm
just going to be a little that give you
a sense of how they would have sung this
theater material when it was all very
weighty still it wasn't a light and
American
I pay
this is very Italian opera right
he can't quite hit these notes
okay well that's just a small taste of
the old sound so I'm going to do a few
other things this as I go through this
stuff with all these different topics
the topics get more modern the whole
music gets more Americanized and you're
going to hear are you going to hear that
eventually in our in our concert I'm
just going to give you two contrasting
sounds they liked it wasn't all just so
amusing from the theater there were
choral pieces that people might sing at
home and I player two contrasting pieces
these are both of 1917 that's a fateful
year because America goes into world war
one and the Jews are now asked to go die
for America and fight their own
relatives in austria-hungary / Germany
this is no joke for American immigrants
at the same time the Russian Revolution
happens which is great liberation and
great joy in the American Jewish
community so there are two songs that do
this text here's the Russian one ok
here's the text on the left Carrie
sounds of freedom to Siberia in the cold
north ok very formal it's very singing
society style this is not theater music
ok and it's done in a Russian
seriousness of purpose minor key ok and
will contrast this with another one
which is on the topic of America and
this one is called my America our new
him
and this sounds like a nice American
patriotic song
da
this is serious so if you ask me to give
my life you need my blood you'll have it
this minute okay I won't even ask why
whatever you want should happen because
this is America notice the great
formality of the English sacrifice and
in a trice that woods to prove okay so
this is a Syria and that's no joke that
it's called to him and this is
surprising you know but it's 1917 so
these are some of the songs I'm going to
play you a much funnier one that's much
more Americanized and gets us to the
theme of the vibration Luca that show we
just saw this is the song text and we'll
look at the sound text and I'll play it
for you because that's easier ok or what
this is yes that this is Viper magnet
for president women make me president
make me a president and we will control
the men and answers cognate King dinner
viber they don't cook dinner and a vast
nichkhun typos okay don't wash any
diapers don't go to the country that's
like the Catskills the country when the
summer comes arm of the men are going to
stay home and they frolic pink v Isaiah
them like pigs the train will bring them
up to the catskills every week and we
don't know what they're doing in the
city they may be having affairs whatever
so this is this is quite the song okay
and this the kind of stuff that I really
got a kick out kick out of because here
we are talking about real
Americanization and the kind of view of
Yiddish immigrant culture that you
absolutely don't get anywhere else when
I was doing this work Irving house world
of our fathers came out world of our
fathers big Tom very serious about the
Jews and the radical social movements
and
blah blah blah he had nothing like this
in the book and partly I did this whole
project because I thought this was
really fun and these people were more
interesting than they were given credit
for and here's this song sounds like
Gilbert solid almost in so of this is
another world there are evelopment vel
telas what you say in theaters um it's a
small it's a world with little small
worlds inside it microcosms but probably
my out of time well um I wanted us to
sing something and what will sing
something um okay let's see where did I
put it oh okay this is the chorus from a
song called the New York tears and let's
sing that this is a really deep than
American songs the chorus is tells you
about all the terrible things that
happened in New York Jews who come here
and what we're living with and this is
the refrain Oh some sign in The New
Yorker clown and those cannon came all
new toy heaven can let's try out those
sign in d new yorker kevin was cannon
came on it I feel in a Chris I guess
they are zips on ave those can't your
Navi ml dog
alright let's try that our class oh gosh
way ours it's una vey the skandian re mi
da heaven dots is sewing it time for
we're gettin off our bow zeth you the
new yorker 12
hmm what is this this the new york tears
that will never stop a class that's a
Mona sob I guess a a scream a shout as
if a sigh and ave amount of pain you can
always hear that here it's not new and
wherever you go just as you pass by
you're going to see the new york tears
so let's try that through once and then
i won't knock off right auto assign
indie New York Italian voice canon came
on you go human I cuz I guess ray ozzie
on avait does can't you don't ever the
heaven does this on me not forget your
farm I zeth here d New York trailer
thank you very much one question we're
switching to notice that's it a
wonderful walls yeah so these you cannot
help by them
the music itself or the fact that day
yes that's in the 20s y ser Jing well I
mean that's business it's just a
business out proper search this is by
the 20s and those are advanced tunes for
weddings and they're like fake books you
know their tunes for going out on gigs
and playing Yiddish tunes because there
weren't any so he was the first guy to
publish what we would call later fake
boats lead sheets too you know so you
can go out and play gigs that's the
world of quarter which is another talk
all together but they're so that's not
songs we're we're dealing with dr. 119
seven years along no no this was that
was in the seventies it was later
there's a couple years after I did that
mid-70s up they were still just sitting
around they were huge they published
masses of things textbooks on literature
world literature everybody who knew you
had big library the liturgical
liturgical and liturgical books of
people came home from as much after they
read Voltaire and Mark Twain and Jack
London and editions from
and books of etiquette stuff like that
all right thank you my name is Mickel ox
I've been asked by the management to
give this pre-concert lecture for
tonight's premiere performance of our
latest production d golden acala the
golden bride now I know almost all of
you in this room are recent Jewish
immigrants or children of immigrants and
you also be get a shat home but i'll
speak in english tonight just to give
you practice in your new language this
morning at breakfast you may have found
this ad in your daily paper for the
first time friday evening februari ninth
that's what's sorry that's tonight
there'll be a premiere of a new yiddish
operetta by joseph from shinsky the
golden bride so for the rest of this
evening you won't have to struggle with
English and if you think you're having
trouble with English wait till you meet
young Jerome a character in tonight's
production you'll laugh because he's an
American who has trouble speaking
Yiddish for example he comes out on
stage calling out con ella con ella now
Torbor the innkeeper's wife is puzzled
basta con ella what's the discontent
live what does that mean another
character explains to her i mayn't avada
han allah he really means canola which
is type his own daughter now I Canada
hoisted in the fest he can't pronounce
the foot sound now it's already dark
outside that you can see on Second
Avenue Rialto and the other stages of
brimming with dramas melodramas comedies
vaudeville's variety shows and operettas
you may remember room since keys first
grated at this theater for years ago the
more Evans niggun the rabbi's melody and
I shouldn't tell you this but there'll
be a surprise visit in tonight's
performance by the lead singer from that
operetta performing some music from the
show
from that show now because I was asked
to give this pre-concert talk tonight I
watched yesterday's final rehearsal and
I guarantee you this operetta would be
so popular it's going to run for the
whole rest of the season another 18
weeks and then you can be sure it's
going to be exported all over Boston
Chicago London buenas iris maybe even
Omaha Nebraska well after all I mean
room since Keys dejes enter the Cantor's
wife played in the Opera House in
Lawrence Kansas a few years ago most
operettas are forgotten as soon as the
first run closes but i'm sure that gold
makalah will be so successful you'll be
seeing revivals of this decades from now
that's because it gives us a window into
our own dreams and values and also into
the trials that we Jews face for the
next 20 minutes or so i want to i want
you to see in here how this work is
carefully tailored to be especially
meaningful to tonight's audience
yiddish-speaking jews who came with our
families to this country during the
massive immigration from Eastern Europe
that began in the 1880s and has
continued for 40 years if you're younger
you may already have been born here but
you still speak Yiddish at home you're
probably poor you live in a cramped
tenement on New York's Lower East Side
and you work hard to eke out a living
for the Yiddish theater is where we
gather with family and friends where we
can get distracted from our day-to-day
lives and feel completely at home and as
you'll see the concept of home plays a
very big role in this operetta the
composer joseph from shinsky was born in
1881 year Vilna major Jewish Center and
what was then still Russian Lithuania
and is now the Soviet Union in 1903 he
escaped to London to avoid being
conscripted into the Czar's army and
while in London he continued his music
studies with Ebenezer proud a respected
classical music composer and conductor
room shinsky arrived in America the
following year and soon became the
leading composer of utich operettas he's
already being called the Jewish Victor
Herbert he's producing operettas at a
remarkable pace in this rate he's going
to write music for a hundred I can
assure you luis gil rod who wrote the
lyrics was born in a small town in
ukraine his father brought him to
America when he was still a kid in fact
he was around 10 and he left him with an
uncle in newark new jersey now Gil Ramos
wrote mostly serious songs but he also
collaborated on a vaudeville skit that
dared to compare Tsar Nicholas to
Charlie Chaplin from shinsky thinks this
libretto is by Lewis Fryman but it
wasn't it was actually written by
Louis's wife Frieda Fryman and here's
the proof the first page of the libretto
manuscript deposited for copyright at
the Library of Congress in Washington
and registered last June tenth 1922
reads d called makalah then there's a
double underline then comedy in three
acts by frida Fryman the actors will see
in the show tonight a mostly
professionals of the addition typically
though not always from acting families a
few were born in the US but most either
immigrated themselves like rum Shinsky
or were brought to this country as
children like Gil road the setting of
Act one is a Russian shtetl a largely
Jewish town perhaps like the Polish town
of wawa pardon me which is pictured here
if you didn't grow up in a shtetl
yourself you're still very familiar with
the setting from hearing your parents
talk about the old country or from the
stories of Yiddish writers like Sean
life mx2 and three take place in a
wealthy home here in America the sort of
place most of us dream about but have
never seen here's the story Golda is a
supposed orphan who comes of age
suddenly inherits a fortune left by her
estranged father who had recently died
in America
and when she hears this she cries out
long live my dead father who left me
such a large inheritance and the chorus
ances long live her dead father now she
is rich so she attracts a flock of
suitors but she promises to marry the
first one who brings her her birth
mother and nobody says not brett has to
make sense now there's a family of five
in this show there's a father a mother a
son a daughter and their ward Golda the
father is the innkeeper stock character
in the Yiddish theater his wife is tybo
who will be portrayed tonight by Annie
Tomashevsky she and her brother boris
thomashefsky are two members of the most
celebrated family in the Yiddish theater
you've seen them in many shows I'm sure
Hana or connellan the diminutive is
Pincus pimp in class and Tobi's daughter
and Misha is their son the hero of our
story who is studying at the University
which is quite a thing for a kid for
metal Misha will be played tonight by
michal mija lesko the handsome 35 year
old matinee idol of the Irish theater
shown here with his co-star Lucy Finkel
who plays gold or gold Allah the golden
bride of the title Golda was left by her
mother as a young at a young age to be
raised in the innkeeper's family which
makes her a kind of an orphan the orphan
is as you know a favorite character in
the Yiddish theater and is supposed to
inspire sympathy in all you Jewish
mothers out there you know that Golda
will be at the center of a happy ending
and you know from Misha's first song in
which he expresses his love for gold who
is going to win her in the end then
there are two visitors from America gold
is uncle in his son the uncle Benjamin
is a millionaire now his name in the
Yiddish script is spelled out
phonetically Benjamin to make it clear
that he's adopted the English form of
his Hebrew name which in Yiddish would
be Benjamin Benjamin son Jerome was
probably named after some deceased
ancestor maybe Joel or Jacob or Joseph
certainly not st. Jerome the young man
is so thoroughly Americanized he barely
speaks Yiddish of course the play is in
Yiddish so the actor playing him has to
speak Yiddish throughout but at least he
makes lots of mistakes and throws in
lots of English words and then there are
three suitors of golden who are
deliberately caricatured each one makes
a ridiculous pitch for Golda's hand
burka the cobbler swears he would be as
true to her as a shoe sole yong-chol the
tailor would give up his sewing needle
and scissor to marry her and Mutko the
choir singer would even give up his
tuning fork the show opens with the
course of villagers singing excitedly
about the millionaire from America and
his son who are visiting the shtetl he
has sacks of gold 100 railroad cars he
stuffed with money and he'll make us
rich the singing and dancing start out
happily rejoice everybody rejoice good
times are coming good friends from
America from far away will help us but
the mood turns critical especially of
the dollar which they say can buy
anything or anyone the shtetl characters
like many of us here dream about money
but don't have very much and the show's
characters the show's creator sorry play
right into this dichotomy by both
admiring and disparaging the dollar most
Jews right now of course have so strong
socialist or even communist tendencies
and the taint of capitalism represented
by the almighty dollar is clear in this
excerpt now on these recordings you'll
hear that the singers don't always
follow the text exactly now let's see if
I can get this to work
now I mentioned an incident that makes
fun of Jerome's American pronunciation
of Yiddish in the second number of the
show jerome in his broken yiddish sings
about the freedom in the united states
and describes the wonders there he talks
about the elevators on the subway zetman
dot you see elevators and subways there
since Prohibition this prohibition on
mcclintock he had not and there's
drinking everywhere when Jerome says
he's in love with Canela tybo asked him
how can you love my daughter when you've
known her for only two weeks his answer
with us in America in two weeks you fall
in love you get married you get divorced
and you get married again
now Jerome promises he'll take good care
of Connell adding in English so help me
God so he's asked to swear to that in
Yiddish and so he thinks very hard and
he finally comes out with a za zelma
helfen Jesus so help me Jesus we're
hardly 10 minutes into the show and
they've already made fun of money
Americans English and even religion and
speaking of religion for most of us here
the synagogue has been replaced as a
social center by the theater but even a
secular Jews we've all been raised in a
Jewish environment so a nod to religious
ritual is part of almost every year to
stage plot sure enough as the finale to
act 1 Misha sings kiddush prayer to
welcome the Sabbath and too many of us
the ceremony will bring back happy
memories of grandma lighting friday
night candles tasty friday night meals
from Shin skis music for the kiddush
sounds just as the way a cantor and a
synagogue might improvise it you'll hear
words and phrases repeated typical
feature of Jewish cantorial style the
soloist in this recording is in fact a
well-known cancer you'll hear the use of
the so-called fraga SH mode a variation
of the Phrygian mode based on a scale
that sounds like this orrrr the interval
between the second and third notes of
the scale is called an Augmented second
Dom DOM it's part of what makes it sound
Jewish or more accurately East European
the scale is the basis for a lot of
Jewish cantorial singing as well as
Yiddish klezmer music and yet his songs
that you probably sing at home and here
at weddings like I've Nagila there it is
again it's one of the musical devices
chosen by Rome Shinsky to connect the
show with the audience this excerpt is
going to start in the middle
Oh
this would be the synagogue choir
repeating what the gospel singing now
we've just heard a religious ritual if
there's such a thing as a secular ritual
in the edge theater it's a lullaby which
reminds folks at their childhood and in
addition that's the mothers in the
audience to remember the sweet
connections between mother and baby gold
is thinking about how she wants her
birth mother whom she calls her real
mother her emison mama to attend her
wedding and remembers her mother singing
her to sleep I'll skip over this well
I'll tell you about this I this is the
lead sheet that room shinty will be
conducting from tonight showing only the
vocal lines for the instrumental
sections and and for the instrumental
sections only the melody of what the
orchestra is playing now yet is uses the
Hebrew alphabet and like Hebrews written
from right to left music of course reads
left to right so how do you get around
this well the music moves in the normal
way left to right but the words are
broken into syllables each syllable
reading right to left which makes it a
little tricky to read but you get used
to it in the show tonight you'll hear
Golda tenderly remembering her mother
singing three different lullabies to her
of course using borrowed music is a
time-honored practice in musicals the
second lullaby which begins your father
from your childhood in America fits into
the story so well it could have been
written for this show but it actually
dates from 30 years ago we'll hear the
third classic
by a Russian song with lyrics by the
poet me claremont grove Finkel has
defined soprano voice that's
unfortunately a bit distorted in this
pressing
the yearning for Russia for your shtetl
for your home for your childhood is a
major subtext of the entire upper edit
reflects the feelings that many of us
had here have for home even though for
most of us life is clearly better in
America the idea of home is expressed
repeatedly in gold nikala as Misha is
coming home from the University and
nearing home in the early in the story
he and tones arrest at Eve in the quasar
cantorial style beginning Hainsey suhane
literally home sweet home a conscious
allusion to the Stephen Foster lyric and
you can buy this record in the theatre
la vie for the younger folks here I'll
explain why Russian and the Russian
language plays a larger role plays a
large role in this Yiddish operetta Tsar
Alexander the third ascended to the
imperial throne in 1881 and immediately
began a vigorous policy of anti-semitism
resulting in oppressive laws expulsion
xand programs in which Jews were
murdered by the thousands we in this
holler among two million refugees who
have come to America since the 1880s
fleeing the Russian Empire and then from
various Russian Wars the last one of
which ended in 1921 just two years ago
even so many of us still nurture the
hope of returning someday to a free
Russia the ideal communist state and
this yearning for home is repeatedly
reflected in the operetta a greeting
from the new Russia is one of two
numbers from the show for which sheet
music has been issued and it's already
been recorded and you can buy record
from the lobby the music for the cars
section is a march based on a
traditional song doobie noski which we
saw few moments ago which conveys the
strength of the characters convictions
for the end of the refrain the language
churches to the original Russian I
should mention that the famous shalyapin
recorded the song back in 1908
the transliteration is tattooed Russian
theater Yiddish it's not gay
in a lot personal yo girl
he never seen a blond female line of
England control
but praise for America is heard over and
over again as well so at tonight's
performance you'll hear Jerome singing
America is a land where everybody is
free and everyone who lives there is
faithful to the country you can see
wonders there in endless miracles it's
the best and the greatest believe me and
I think you'll be surprised to hear this
instrumental example of American music
in the middle of the Yiddish operetta
thank you now so far we've seen the
works Korea to serve up many devices
designed to play into our specific
feelings and memories and to connect
with us as Jewish immigrants from Europe
but there's more the sinequan of every
operetta love if Misha is going to marry
gold at the end of the operator he first
has to show that he's in love with her
and he has to overcome obstacles like
finding gold his mother and finally win
her every Yiddish operetta audience
actually every operetta audience wants
to hear a beautiful love song the duet
mine gold Allah is expected to be such a
favorite that it's also been issued as
cheap music and it's also for sale in
the lobby well now he listened to the
first verse in the chorus sung by
michael s co and Finkel
Oh
this piece represents one more way the
operator is the operetta is tailored to
it's Yiddish audience every Jewish
mother in this theater wants to see her
daughter married and in the old country
that meant when a girl reach maturity of
parents might go to a matchmaker who
would seek out the perfect husband for
her in real life the process can be
highly emotional but in gold makalah
it's an excuse for a couplet number an
opportunity for ad libbing topical
references usually as humorous insults
kallmann the matchmaker goes up to every
female on stage and sings to each one
that he has a perfect match for her
we'll hear two verses on the following
recording
not what I mean
who is it ain't sorrow mainly charge it
employs a clean it up now this piece
represents one more way I'm sorry that's
I said that already a mamaliga by the
way is a Romanian cornmeal dish now I'm
going to read you one more verse and
you'll notice that the nouns are all in
English hopefully avater was conversion
dishes do you need a translation others
I've as he's also as a car salesman by
Jana Schimmel's knishes he's a salesman
at your national snitch bakery now hocus
pocus we're now back in new haven in the
21st century and I can tell you that
Janish emeralds bakery is celebrating
its a hundred and fifth year in business
still at the same address on the Lower
East Side finally here's a scene from
the last act of the gold nikala showing
all the happy couple's at the wedding of
gold and misha shane em down isn't given
guta I Ciara thank you you've been a
great audience
one question then we're going to take a
short break there's nothing for sale in
the lobby we do have a small little
token for you also take away it's a
small commemorative CD of examples of
Yiddish song from the historical sound
recordings collection yells music
libraries so he'll be out there for you
to take with you there's also a little
reception following the recital so one
question for Michael at first I had one
announcement yet that I was asked to
make the national initiative folks bina
actually Purdue a did a performance of
this with piano concert performance last
May and it's going to be repeated in
August on August fifth at Rutgers
University you're all welcome except
this time they're going to do it with
some instruments so anyway now if
anybody has a question yes yeah oh
absolutely there's no question I'm I
have no evidence but i'm sure that room
shinsky newsnews some Gilbert and
Sullivan
you